all right so I know that some people are
not going to like this segment and
that's okay as long as we're able to
have a productive conversation about it
and I put aside the time on today's show
to actually be able to do this we are
about to head into an election of
extreme importance insofar as the
removal of Donald Trump this is not just
politically based but there are a number
of different just systemic weaknesses in
our democracy by virtue of having Donald
Trump in the oval office we're looking
now at a delay of the census which I'll
talk about on tomorrow's program
relationships with countries abroad I
mean this is way bigger than Republicans
and Democrats and more and more
Republicans by the way are understanding
this when it comes to Donald Trump we
cannot be distracted on the left by
self-destructive impulses and last week
I did live streams of the the two
debates the one debate that was split
into two nights and after the second
night of debating ended with the
Democrats
I took some live calls and I got a live
call from a woman who wanted to explain
to me that there can be no such thing as
racism against white people and there
can be no such thing as racism by people
of color or minorities in the United
States now I got pretty agitated during
the call and now that a few days have
gone by I've sort of reflected on why
and realize that it's not the
disagreement in and of itself that I
found so disturbing and so agitating but
it's that the conversation in and of
itself is one that when it becomes as
toxic as it did is the type of thing
that can either destroy the left or
potentially seriously hurt us and I
don't want to see that happen so I'm
gonna play the full clip for you because
I don't want to take any one piece of it
out of context this is the full
conversation I had during live calls
after the debate last week from a caller
saying white people can't be the victims
of racism non-white people can't be
racist
in the United States take a listen to
this let's see who else we've got here
let's go to oh I don't know I mean I'm
just going going crazy here with area
codes let's try let's try the people er
something's up with the phone system
there's almost like too many people
holding let's try the five six one area
code who's calling today from five six
one hello yes that's you I have a
question it's really relating to the
debate why I called the way before and
it was it was I think it was mentioned
on your interview with the Joe Rogan
show and it was about that we of that
one woman who try to get you fired from
Boston College because you tweeted that
it's not progressive to vote for someone
are not vote for someone based off of
their race gender well you yeah yeah
yeah I said that excluding candidates
merely because of their race or gender
is not progressive and she tried to get
me fired from Boston College for saying
that right so what you said on the Joe
Rogan show and imply that what she was
saying was racist and I called asking
what you thought about that because
racism isn't applicable to white people
and I really wanted to hear yourself
from that because yeah who says you
can't be racist against white people
well okay we have to really take a look
at what racism is because if we're going
by the definition by its discriminating
or seeing a race as above or below
another that's a very skewed definition
where racism should be examining the
social economic and political system and
within this nation and other anglo-saxon
nations there's only one group the
in-group which are white people that
have political socio-economic power to
oppress no totally disagree with you I
think that's a losing let's that's a
losing redefinition of racism
you can be there's no question that
power dynamics are really important in
thinking about whether racism trans
into structural oppression but you can
be racist no matter what your races and
no matter what one other people's race
is I think it's exciting is extremely
problematic but why is my definition of
problematic when it takes into account
the historical implications of what
white people have a group have done to
oppress people it's just not it's just
not the right it's just not accurate
you're the first definition you gave is
the right one and so I think there's two
things because it's not what racism
you're just you're coming up with a new
definition it's like if I said you know
well you've presented another definition
right and I think I'm presenting the
most accurate and holistic definition of
racism and that's what so for you the
most accurate definition of racism is
one in which no one can be racist
against white people is that what you're
saying that's what you said that's how
you started the conversation you said
you can't be racist against white people
in Western anglo-saxon countries you
can't be racist always in this nation in
this and this nation specifically
because that's what I've studied with
racism this nation specifically you
can't be racist to white people because
people of color don't have the power
okay hold on a second just hold on one
second okay let me let's just take it
let's let's build it up if a Hispanic
person says I don't like white people
because they're white is that racist no
it's not racist however how is that no
however just how is it not racist it's
not racist because okay well I can't I
can't say Hispanic because Hispanic is
an ethnicity so I understand what you
mean by let's say person of color a
person of color cannot be racist towards
the white person because they don't have
the power okay all right fine so so look
we're going through just indulge me if
if a person of color says I don't like
white people because of their whiteness
that's not racist according to you if
they complain if a company says if a
company says we are not going to hire
white people
at this company is that racist yeah it's
racially bigoted it's racially bigoted
really like I think it's lice or left
that you represent is very small but it
is extremely problematic and I
completely disagree okay how do I want
to I follow you because I think you're
really reasonable and I subscribe to you
and I think it's great what you do and
what you're saying is extraordinarily
unreasonable trust in my reason then
however one thing is not like some
conspiracy theorist idea it's not wrong
because we have people studying race and
racism for decades and anthropologists
have come together to you're just wrong
listen a second I'm I'm a Hispanic
immigrant to this country if I said I am
going to enact it hold on a second if
you really want to get down into
ethnicity I'm actually asking Ozzie but
this is a whole this is why this is so
stupid if I say no matter what my race
is if I'm white if I'm Hispanic if I'm
Ashkenazi if I said the David Pakman
show is not going to hire white people
as a policy because I just don't like
having white people around that is
racist by any definition of the word and
any deviation from that is completely ok
prejudice but racism needs to take the
holistic definition of prejudice plus
power listen now you're just playing now
you're just playing semantics and I'm
gonna let you go cuz the audience I
think is tuning out but you're just
wrong I would urge you to rethink your
views and I hope that that does not
infect any of the Democratic candidates
dialog because that is self de sayin is
a disaster it's it's it's
extraordinarily damaging and fortunately
it I don't think it's super prevalent
because what you're saying doesn't make
any sense okay well I mean I'm shocked
by that I'm shocked by that
so the mistake I made in this clip aside
from just getting more agitated than I
might have wanted to is that I actually
completely missed really getting into
the big picture of what's wrong here
because yeah I mean racism doesn't
require systemic oppression to be racism
I would have been better off during the
call distinguishing and saying I
appreciate your perspective I think
we're talking about the difference
between racism and systemic or
structural oppression on the basis of
racist beliefs racism can exist without
using those racist beliefs to oppress a
particular group of people
either way it's racism right whether
it's racism plus oppression or racism
without oppression either way it's
racism but now that I've actually had
some more time to reflect about the call
and I talked to a bunch of people about
it over the weekend the real problem
here is that this type of argument
literally prevents actually talking
about solutions what I mean by that is
I've talked about the narcissism of
small differences before I've talked
about the importance of not missing the
forest for the trees when we talk about
politics and policy and what we want to
see I believe that clearly people of
color can be racist
I believe that obviously white people
can be the victims of racism the
requiring oppression to be racist makes
no sense to me in the same way that if
you have a KKK member in the middle of
West Virginia with racist beliefs but no
resources to actually oppress anybody
living in a rural place where there
isn't even anybody to oppress that's
still a racist right in the same way a
person of color can be racist against
white people they may or may not have
the ability resources wherewithal or
circumstances to oppress white people
because those people are white but they
can still be racist but here's the real
issue this caller and I I would guess
would agree that in the United States
the issues of racism have to be sort of
understood big picture and that mostly
issues of racism in the United States
our racism against people of color not
racism against white people the caller
and I I'm guessing would agree that in
the United States historically most
racism but not all has been against
people of color and not by them
and it has been by white people and not
against them that's a historical reality
but look at how this however long it was
six minute conversation we end up in an
argument that's not only unwinnable
she was totally set in this idea that
white people simply cannot be the
victims of racism period like at a a
priori in an a priori sense it's an
argument that will never solve anything
imagine that I argued with her for an
additional hour and imagine that she got
me to agree okay you know what you're
right you can't be racist against white
people it would do nothing for the
majority of victims of racism in the
United States who are people of color in
the United States this is completely
self-destructive it's energy and time
that is being spent on something that is
not going to achieve change for us it is
not going to put us in a better position
to put leaders in place that are going
to do good things rather than bad things
for us so the argument about whether a
person of color can be racist where are
the lines between ethnicities I'm of
Hispanic culture but a white person but
at the same time I'm ash can assi which
anti-semites say are not actually white
people but I still look white and speak
without an accent and you which category
that this is a loser's argument the
argument does nothing for us in trying
to fix the issues that we're facing in
the United States it does nothing for us
in trying to replace Donald Trump with
the most progressive possible candidate
whoever we believe that to be and that's
really why I was so frustrated okay
someone disagrees with me about the
definition of racism I I understand the
prejudice plus power definition of
racism has been
in academic settings and sociology
departments for a while it can be
debated I mean the caller presented it
as obviously that's the right definition
well the idea that you need prejudice
plus power and depression for something
to qualify as racism is not something
that is unanimously agreed upon that
there that that's it I don't even want
to get into that debate again because I
think that that is secondary or even
tertiary here the argument I had with
the caller does nothing for me and I
wish that I had instead said hey you
know what I actually don't think it
matters how we each define racism I
think you're obviously wrong by the way
let's figure out what policies we want
in order to ease the issues that are
biased along racial lines in the United
States my guess is and I hope I'm not I
mean I'm being charitable I hope I'm not
being overly charitable I know some
people will hear this and they'll say
David you were not going to have any
sensible conversation with that person I
I think maybe we could have my guess is
that mostly our list of problems could
be fixed and policy prescriptions could
be agreed upon even if we couldn't agree
as to the definition of racism which
again I totally agree with that caller
about so let me know what you think
because my concern is that is the type
of argument which number one is
completely fruitless in terms of we
would what we would gain from continuing
for an additional 16 minutes instead of
just 6 or 60 minutes or 600 minutes and
if the left gets pulled into that type
of stuff it is going to take attention
it is going to take resources and time
is a resource and other resources away
from actually making the decisions and
becoming activists to really affect
change and that is why I found it so
agitating and frustrating I want to know
what you think okay I'm on Twitter at
Dee Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show
was that a debate worth having or not
how big a slice of the left do you
believe that ideology represents and am
I generally right that it is a
destructive
is a distractive and potentially
self-destructive path for the left to go
down at a time where we are approaching
such an important election in the United
States of America let me know Twitter @d
Pakman